We took an in-depth look at the fitness regimens
employed by some of your favorite Marvel stars,
with an emphasis on the diets and workouts
they used leading up to the MCU's big showdown
against Thanos.
Lupita Nyong'o went through bootcamp
Lupita Nyong'o is a relative newcomer to the
MCU her first Marvel film was 2018's Black
Panther and she put in a lot of work to get
in shape.
"We had six weeks of bootcamp, where they
got us all buff and ready to go."
Fortunately, she enjoyed the physical challenge.
Nyong'o said:
"It's just gaining strength, stamina, and
flexibility…
I had to get into particularly good shape
to be able to do the stunts."
The bootcamp worked, and her physical skill
as Nakia is evident.
It's easy to imagine that her workout routine
for Avengers: Endgame rests on continuing
to train hard and put on muscle.
Karen Gillan did martial arts
Karen Gillan debuted as Nebula in the Guardians
of the Galaxy franchise before appearing in
Infinity War and Endgame, and she didn't skimp
as she prepared for the role.
Squats, barbell deadlifts, and other weightlifting
moves played a big role in her workout routine;
cardio like running and cycling upped her
endurance so she could last during the long
days on set.
Next came martial arts training.
As Gillan put it:
"I had to start from the scratch in terms
of learning how to fight, to look like I could
do damage to someone."
Finally, she also transformed her diet: eating
protein shakes, apples, and almond butter
all helped Gillan get the protein she needed
in order to build more muscle and step into
the role of Nebula.
"It's not ripe."
Chris Pratt went for trail runs
Chris Pratt, better known as Star-Lord to
Marvel fans, took to Instagram to share his
Avengers: Infinity War workout.
In the videos on his Instagram stories, Pratt
took a three-mile trail run as a warm-up and
then did three sets of 120-yard hill sprints.
Pratt went through an intensive training regimen
for Guardians of the Galaxy, working for three
or four hours each day and losing 60 pounds
in just six months.
During that time, Pratt also gave up alcohol,
ate 4,000 calories a day in a low-carb diet,
and did swimming, boxing, P90X, running, kickboxing,
and even a triathlon as part of his workout
routine.
So when it came time to prepare for Infinity
War and Endgame, Pratt was prepared he knew
what it would take.
And it seems like Pratt enjoys his workouts,
too.
"I can do 40-inch box jumps now.
Action-hero physical stuff.
Jumping that high feels really good.
When you get in shape, the world around you
becomes things you want to jump on and climb
on."
“Oh my God are you Okay?
“Yeah, I’m good.”
Josh Brolin gave up carbs
When Josh Brolin first started preparing to
play Cable in Deadpool 2, he went the low-carb
route right away: No sugar.
No bread.
No pastas.
It can be a difficult diet to follow, but
it's also one that can produce results that
is much evident by watching Brolin as Thanos
in Avengers: Infinity War.
In addition to exercising his self-control
in the kitchen, Brolin put in the work in
the gym, too Gold's Gym, according to the
location on some of his Instagram workout
videos.
Brolin performed drop sets and other workout
moves with his trainer, Justin David Lovato
of Built Nutrition and Training.
He's definitely put in the work, and although
he can now enjoy his role as Thanos, that
role came at a heavy price.
"What did it cost?
Everything."
Robert Downey Jr. stayed loose
Can you picture Iron Man doing yoga?
That suit would definitely make it difficult,
but in real life, Robert Downey Jr. is an
ardent enthusiast.
In 2008, Downey described his infatuation
with yoga, telling TIME,
"I need a lot of support…
Life is really hard.
I've just been at the ready, and when the
opening was there, I hit it."
Downey was in the news for an assortment of
dangerous behaviors many years ago, and he's
said yoga is a big part of what helped him
improve his overall health and wellness and
stay on the straight and narrow.
"It is Robert Downey Jr.
“Wow!"
"That's RDJ?"
Yoga isn't a shocking or particularly exciting
workout; it doesn't make headlines like some
of the other intense regimens other Marvel
actors put themselves through.
But Downey doesn't stop there, either.
"I train kung fu I strength train, I do chi-gong,
I do Susan Downey’s workout is Tracy Anderson."
Year-round fitness
By now, we're pretty deep into the Marvel
universe more than 20 movies deep, in fact
and many of Marvel's primary actors have been
around for a while.
That's why they continue working out all year
long, even if they aren't training for any
specific film.
Chris Hemsworth, in particular, maintains
a consistent workout routine to stay in shape
for playing Thor.
When it's time to really gear up for his next
MCU adventure, he can pack on as much as 20
pounds but in between movies, he keeps going
to the gym, albeit at a more low-key level.
There's no reason for the cast to keep up
their punishing six-day-a-week workout schedule
if they aren't preparing to film.
But continuing some form of consistent exercise
can help them stay healthy and also stay prepared.
By keeping up with workouts, they won't have
as much work to do in order to get back in
fighting shape for the next movie.
"Look, The other thing about these big genre
movies is that you don’t want to be the
tubby guy."
Nutrition and mobility
Through focusing on year-round fitness, staying
in shape all the time so they'll be ready
for the next Marvel film, some of the MCU's
stars have developed a life-altering affinity
for healthy living.
Chris Hemsworth has even launched a health,
fitness, and diet app, which helps subscribers
set goals and then complete short, focused
workouts to reach them.
"Mindfulness, training, nutrition, general health and
well being, and thought wouldn't it be cool
if I could bring all those people together into one space and give you guys access to that team."
Like the rest of us, the MCU cast isn't getting
any younger and a persistent focus on regular
exercise and sensible nutrition is always
a great way to stay in shape, whether you're
simply staying healthy or gearing up for a
blockbuster movie like Avengers: Endgame.
To see how more Avengers actors got in shape,
watch this video right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Endgame
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.